Okay, welcome another Zoom call reminder to keep asking questions on the member site.
Years ago, we used to have people ask questions to their liaison to and Ashley.
We asked that you don't do that any longer that you asked the questions on the member site.
Ashley is not even with us anymore. She's home with her baby though.
and done and has been working just very important with her son's condition.
So please ask your questions via the member site.
And then remember that we'll answer your questions if you asked them.
If you submitted a question between this Wednesday Zoom call and the Monday Zoom call,
it will most likely be answered on that that Monday Zoom call. So if you didn't get a chance to
get on it, remember to look at that Zoom call. Watch it to get your questions answered.
If you submitted a question between Monday Zoom call and this Wednesday, of course, it's going
to be on this one. At least we do our best to do that. Reminder again that all courses are available
to all of you. It's the same log in that you use to get on the member site for any of the courses.
Okay, in addition to a variant cancer, I have lymphedemia. So lymphedema is common with many other
cancers, many conditions. You can get lymph stasis. You're recommend using a rebounder how much time should
I use per day, currently do five minutes a day. So there's pros and cons to doing the rebuilder.
I know the companies that sell the rebuilders, of course, they push all the pros to it.
There is cons to doing it as well. If you know it, that you have a test basis to
anything to bold, especially you do it to be careful on the rebounder, that you're not bouncing too much,
because that force, it's a matter of physics with the trampoline that force goes up through your
joints again. And even though I'm not pounding on the pavement, that's good, but you still get that
rebound force that goes up through your spine. So the amatastasis to the spine, especially, I don't
highly recommend the rebounder. You have to be very careful with it or very gently with it, or just do
walking on it. You can also use the rebounder in different ways, where you just get on it,
do leg razors, where you go up on your toes and down. You can do that on the ground as well,
but sometimes it's a little, you do it flexing different muscles when you're on a trampoline,
doing that. Just make sure you have something that you're holding onto.
And also with lymphediva in the lower extremities, especially, doing any sort of motion. So remember,
your lymph system is an open-ended capillary system in those capillaries. Do not have a heart
to pump the fluid through like your arteries and your veins do. So they rely on contraction muscles.
So any time that you could do any type of muscular contract doesn't have to be,
you know, it doesn't have to be even walking, certainly not running. You could just do muscular
contraction. So even if you're sitting in the chair, that you're riding it out in the alphabet,
that's your toes, you're drawing a picture with your toes, you're using your imagination,
a drawing a picture with your hands with upper extremity lymphediva. You're contracting your muscles,
you're moving your arms, you're moving your legs, that's the whole idea. So any type of motion is good,
but you could track the muscles, you push the fluid through the lymph vessels and then there's
been one way valid about every two to four inches and it pushes the fluid through that it can't go
back down. So that's the idea of getting fluid through your body. So I think I have a couple of
blog posts of moving lymph that could be helpful as well. There's a lot of information
about Google because there's actually some lived specialists that are doing massage therapy work
for lymphedema, which can be extremely beneficial as well. So lots of things to think about that
can help with that. So how often should I do the remiller really depends on some of the things that
I just mentioned. You can certainly do more than five minutes a day and you certainly have to do
more than five minutes a day of different muscle contraction exercises. If you're really going to
be able to lift, we've got to try to do it as often as possible. Some cancer groups were using one
third cup of baking soda and one cup of molasses and taking three teaspoons a day. Thoughts about
using this method. We talked about this at the last Zoom call fairly extensively. So
go back and listen to that I would suggest. There's pros and cons to that. I'm not against doing
anything, trying anything. You do have to remember if you're going to be taking baking so that you are
going to be alkalizing your stomach acid, you will be hindering digestion by doing that.
If you're going to do that protocol, I would highly suggest that you take HCl with your meals then
so that you can get your stomach acid back down to the pH that it needs to be
loaded to digest your food. Otherwise, you're going to end up with other digestive issues
that possibly needs to be along the way. Unfortunately, I'm going to have to start radiation and
chemo treatments. Can you recommend some tips to help minimize the side effects? Also, it is recommended
to increase your protein intake during treatments. So if so, are there any specific protein types
that you'd recommend? And if so, is one with way for college and okay? Or what a plant-based protein
be better? If you're going to take protein powder, we recommend that you use the US enzymes brand
protein-zyme. And the reason why we have chosen that for cancer patients is because of the low content
of glutamine and the thyroid unit, which can be a leader of cancer, but this has a very low content
of that. It's also completely clear-based. It does not use weight, so there's no possibility of any
dairy drivers in it. So it comes in vanilla or it comes in chocolate. So you're going to add this
to a shake with berries. I highly suggest vanilla. Otherwise, the chocolate is quite tasty.
As far as a protocol for doing chemo and radiation, we do have a protocol to support those doing chemo.
You can find it on our blog post. I think it's on the member site as well.
It talks in between 24 hour fast prior to doing chemo. And then we should not take a lot of fun.
into oxidants for at least that 48 hour window after the administration of the chemo.
So I assume this person's talking about a chemotherapy IV. So that's what we're talking about that
48 hour window. So the idea is that chemotherapy is oxidizing the agent and taking it oxidizing the
agent. It's basically a poison that's what a oxidizing agent is. So if you're taking an antioxidant,
which everybody's trying to get antioxidant, why? Because chemicals like toxins and pesticides
and herbicides are oxidizing agents, they're poisons. That's how they kill little bugs because
they're poisons. And that's what they do to your body. And that's what they could do to a cell.
And the reason why they're dangerous oxidizing agents will can be cancer-causing. So
that's why we take antioxidants. So you take fresh fruits and vegetables have a lot of antioxidants in
them. So you're taking antioxidants by eat correctly. But there are antioxidant nutrients,
might even see you would be considered an antioxidant. The low-peic acid would be considered
an antioxidant. Would a thiode, would a thiode precursors be considered an antioxidant? Well that's
why an oncologist will say I don't want to take it any supplements. We're going to do chemo. Well
what they really need is they don't want you to get antioxidants. Because if you're going to do
chemo, oxidizing agents, you don't want to negate the effects of the chemo. So I'm not not
doing chemo just because it's poison. I'm just saying you don't want to be taking an antioxidant
while the chemo is trying to work. So you lay off of those nutrients that are highly antioxidant
in their nature. So you wouldn't take vitamin C, you wouldn't take
curcumin, you wouldn't take alpha-peic acid, you wouldn't take the thiode,
448 hours post chemo. So let's say I'm going to do chemo IV at 9 o'clock Monday morning at last
till noon. So I would wait till noon on Wednesday before I take those types of supplements.
In the chemo protocol, that's in our blog. We also caution against taking
things that will really push the detox occasion pathway. Because that's another argument that a
oncologist would say is that I don't want to take it about, you know, support for phase 1 and phase 2
detox of the liver because we're going to put this chemo in you and you're just going to detoxify it,
you know, well, hopefully you're going to detoxify it. But they don't want you to detoxify it
while it's really doing its work. And there's a lot of talk about out there for years. The chemo really
does its work on the cancer of the first 48 hours. That's why we say a 48 hour window. So you
don't do, you know, you maybe even lay back off of your liver support products for 48 hours,
then you do it again. You know, at my example, at noon on Wednesday, you take those liver support
products again. So then doing at 24 or even 48 hour fast prior to doing chemo can be extremely
helpful. We have had numerous patients that have done that and said it really helped minimize
the side effects. We also have a radiation homeopath for radiation. That's this right there. Nothing
is going to be perfect to pull out radiation. This is just what we've had to help.
Okay. In September after a CT scan, I was told it appeared. I was in remission for
blueberry cancer yesterday. I had a follow-up PET scan. More cancer was found. I meet with the
oncologist tomorrow. Any recommendations or questions to ask? I do not know what she'll recommend.
Cancer was found around the liver. So yeah, this is why, I don't know, I've said for decades that
you know, CT scan and PET scans are great and they are cold standards. Still, they're not going to show
there's any cancer if it's under three billion cells large. Meeting that you could have cancer,
that's two billion cells large, but it doesn't show on the CT scan or on the PET scan and you're
giving it a clean bill of health. That's why you just never, you know, I hate to be, I'm not being
a pessimist, I'm just being a realist. I mean, you should just never assume that you're cancer-free.
I mean, you should just shouldn't. You should just assume that, hey, even if you don't have cancer,
you know, you never have been diagnosed, you should assume you have cancer, then you should be
treating yourself as if because it's just true. So, and you know, and I'm not, you know, not saying
you ever stopped doing anything that you were doing beforehand, but there's, you know,
there's been times where that has happened where people don't think they're, they're, you know,
cancer-free, so they stopped doing everything, you know, the cancer quote-a-quote came back with
a bed that's where it was never going to cover. It really, really is ever going to go out and you
have to keep treating as if that's the wisest thing to do. I don't. I personally, you know, I feel like
I have been in a revision, and I wax off on my diet more than anything, and I keep taking my
supplements and I keep doing the right every day, but I horrible was my diet. I've always been horrible
after my diet, and that's not a good thing, and I've reminded, you know, every once in a while that I
need to get better, especially when I have got paid again, I need to get better, be more disciplined.
So any recommendations or questions to ask, I would just hear them out, see what they say,
and then just politely say thank you very much, I get to get back to it, and I'm going to pray about
this and decide what I want to do. So, you know, they may, I don't, I don't have your chart up, I don't,
you remember what their initial recommendations, but they, what do they have? They have really three
tools, you know, you know, they probably will not do radiation, but they may want to do biopsy, I
wouldn't recommend doing that, but they may want to do chemotherapy. So, and then you say, okay,
well, let me think about it and grab on it on the back to you, and do some of that and some research,
and certainly can have conversation with me and we can talk about it too, and look at those scans.
I do copy animals every other day, after it's done, I feel tiredness coming to my legs for a few hours
that it goes away. I do take minerals and make sure I'm not dehydrated. What is the reason for
the tiredness? I would doubt that it's anything to do with the hydration.
Copy animals really are drawing a lot of water from your body to your colon.
That's not really what they do. So, I would doubt that it was that, and I certainly would, you know,
on that same physiological basis, highly doubt that there's any dematerialization of
your tissues due to the confianum. It's, there's just no evidence of that anywhere. So,
that aches, tiredness in your legs could very well be neurological when you do a confianum,
and you're inputting the tube up your rectum, stimulates the course of neurological pathways
back to the lumbar and sacred plexus, which could cause, you know, reflex fatigue in your muscles
that are coming out and iterated through that same plexus. So, give it a neurological.
More likely than that, it's a parasympathetic stimulus. So, understand your purpose of doing
a confianum is to stimulate the parasympathetics. Well, what does the parasympathetic nervous system
do? Well, a parasympathetic nervous system stimulates an immune response. Yay, that's a win.
Parasympathetic nervous system stimulates a detoxification response because,
well, neurologically, your detoxification pathways are controlled by your parasympathetics.
Parasympathetics are also call-made response. Think of everything that your sympathetics do,
and the parasympathetics do the opposite. So, what are the sympathetics do? Your sympathetics are your
fight flight or freeze mechanism, polar bear jumps down in front of you, your blood pressure goes
sky high to shunt blood to the extremities so that you can run away with that polar bear or fight,
your needles kick into full gear and you go into full fight mode and you're trying to survive,
you're in survival mode. When your parasympathetics are call-meat, you're relaxing, decrease anxiety,
they decrease your blood pressure, they decrease the shunt of blood to your extremities.
That's what you want to kick in that will help you relax and help you go to sleep. So,
really, your response is probably more parasympathetic response, which is actually good,
tiredness you feel in your legs. That's why we suggest doing the coffee enemas in the evening so that you
can just go to bed afterwards if you have to. The only negative thing about that is people that are
highly sensitive to caffeine. The caffeine could keep them awake, but most people tolerate
that pretty well. They're not absorbing a ton of the caffeine, especially if you're not dehydrated.
And you don't have the issue with that. Even though cancer was found in my scan, my CA 125
score was only a five, which is the best score I've ever gotten on that test. Is that an indicator
that my body has low inflammation? No, your CA 125 is a true marker test. Your high sensitivity
sea reactive protein is an inflammatory test. So, a CA 125 score of five, that's your lowest
score that you had on that, tells you that that's an indicator one objective finding that your cancer
is getting better. So, this is why you don't even look, you know, okay, the PET scan is the gold standard,
and we see a hotspot on your liver, so we need to do something. My question is,
do I really? That's just one indicator. This is where you use your, you know, you have to go through
kind of that question error of yourself, you know, okay, am I more tired than I am? Do I have
any more pain? Do I feel worse? You know, these subjective things are just as important, so really
analyze your body and go, you know, if if okay, if you have a PET scan and it shows some hotspots
on your liver or elsewhere in your brain, does that always mean that, you know, you that it is
cancer? Well, yes, no, it doesn't always mean that it's cancer. It's another indicated factor
that there's cancer there, but then you have to weigh that out with other things, your other
subjective findings and your other objective findings. Well, my true markers are continuing to drop.
How can that possibly be? It can be because there always was cancer there, but it just the PET scan
never picked it up before, and it's actually could be actually better than it was, you know, six
months ago. So it doesn't mean that you need to jump into another course of care from standards of care
protocol or anything like that. You have to weigh out any objective,
fighting with other objective findings and with, I'm feeling, you know, let's say the case was,
hey, my C-A125 meeting my other true markers are better, and I'm actually feeling great,
I feel like I had more energy. I don't, you know, then I might say, well, you know, maybe we'll run
this test to get in three months or six months. So it and weigh this all out, you don't just use one
test to determine something. All these things have have, you know, negatives to them, they
can show false positives, and test can show false negatives too. So you want to weigh all these out,
you know, want to put all your eggs in a basket. But again, I would go, you know, have your meeting with
your oncologist, see what they have to say. If they're reasonable and not just a technician of a
practitioner, then they would do the same thing. I think it's what I'm telling you is to be reasonable.
Like, oh, well, this is positive. Could this have been missed before? Yes, the tests, you know,
there's plenty evidence that it could have been missed before. You know, my other tests are doing
well. My blood is doing better. This is doing better. I feel great. Um, I'm sure they're not going
to push you down the course of actions that you don't want to go either. So how many chemo drug types
are there to treat pancreatic cancer? And do you think low dose chemo treatments work better than
normal dose? Well, I'm not an oncologist or a pharmacologist. So I don't know how many chemo drug types
there are to treat pancreatic cancer. So I apologize. I can't answer that, but I know you could just
probably Google that and get a fairly fair statement about that. Do I think low dose chemo treatments
work better than normal dose? No, I don't think they work better. I think they can't be better for
some people. So let's rephrase that maybe. Why would a person want to do low dose chemo
insulin-potentiated chemo therapy is what we're talking about versus doing regular full dose chemo?
What are the pros and cons of that? I'm just giving you my opinion. So the pros of doing full
dose chemo is if you're going to tolerate it, and I mean, is it well tolerated? I mean, you know,
the side effects of it is a destroy your body. That would make more sense because you are going to
hit it hard and you have a better chance of really docking yourself into remission. The problem is
is that many people don't tolerate. Many people, the truth is, let's just be honest, a lot of people
that do chemo are killed by the chemo is what killed them. The chemo was their demise. That's what
brought their body down. I shouldn't say many. There's a percentage, okay? So a percentage, whatever
percentage that is, no one will ever find that data because they'll never do a fair study about that.
But there is a percentage of people that the chemo is their demise, but that's really not
everybody. It's people with more compromised immune systems, people with more compromised health,
people with other cold morbidities, people with compromised detoxification pathways from a
genetic perspective and tissue injuries perspective. Let's say they consume more alcohol than they
should have in their life. They were exposed to more toxins than they should have in their life. So
they have damaged the liver already and they have a compromised liver. They're not going to be
able to detoxify the chemo well or people that just have a genetic predisposition that they don't
detoxify the chemo. Well, they have defects out there. In a tea pathways, they're cytokine P450
pathways and they're chronic pathways a lot more than more people than other people do. So there's
compromised there. They don't detoxify it well. They're going to have more issues with chemo.
But there are some people that detoxify it very well and they could go through chemo and they can
sell through pretty well. Those people tend to have better results with the chemo. Also, there's
cancers that don't respond to chemo. I don't care how much chemo in a person in the tolerate,
the cancer doesn't respond to the chemo. If that's the case, then it's not going to respond to insulin
potentiated low dose chemo either. So if your cancer doesn't respond to full dose chemo,
it's not going to respond to insulin potentiated chemo unless they're using it completely different drug.
So that would be something that's common to both. But there's some people that just don't tolerate
chemo or they believe they're not going to tolerate chemo well. And some of the indications are,
well, I don't detoxify any drugs. Well, I'm not good with any drugs. It seems like I just don't
I react to them. It seems like, you know, I can't I can hardly take Tylenol with, you know,
feeling sick, you know, I just know I don't detoxify medications well at all. I don't think I'll do
well with chemo. Those are the people that would, you know, that where low dose insulin potentiated
chemo therapy would be a perfect fit because you're giving about 10% of the dose of normal dose chemo
while doing a insulin push beforehand, which will cause the cancer to help uptake the chemo therapy
better. Thereby, you could use a lower dose. That's a whole idea of insulin potentiated chemo therapy.
Well, it's not, well, it's not potentiated chemo therapy sounds real great to do. It has some
negative things as well. Number one is what I already spoke of. The cancer isn't going to respond
to any chemo therapy. It's not going to respond to the insulin potentiated low dose chemo therapy either.
The other negative is you have to use to a far more sessions. So usually,
fortunately, because there's a few and far between clinics that actually administer
insulin potentiated chemo therapy, you have to travel to a place, typically in Arizona,
there's another place in Michigan that doesn't, you have to travel there and stay there. So you
have to basically go there and, you know, rent a condom for three months because that's how long
you're going to be there doing it. So that's a negative in a way because while I'm trying to say
my life, so that's not a negative, well, that's okay, but you're going to be away from home if you have
kids at home, it's very difficult to approach your family and do something like that. So that's a
negative. The positive is you're not going to get a sick. You still can lose your hair. You could
still have side effects, but you're not going to get nearly as sick as you would if you were doing
full dose chemo therapy. So there's pros and cons to each one. So I wouldn't say it's something
works better. I'd say it's a different application that fits different people's needs better. So
that would be the answer to that question. Play that helps. Any other questions? Any comments on
the Mexico immutable therapy clinics like this one? No, not really. I mean, we've had patients
go to many different clinics in Mexico prior to coming to us and we've had them go to them while
they're working with us. We haven't really heard. I mean, I'm sure we've heard some negative comments,
but most of them positive. If there was any negative over the years of doing this, I don't remember
at all what clinics they were that were negative because there's other people that said very positive
things about it. Most in general, everybody had a very positive experience. So some of them offer
different things. So look and see what they offer. You certainly, I don't think there's a lot of
value just going to like the girls in clinic where you're going to go down there for two weeks.
They're going to juice for you. But the clinics that offer a bunch of different types of therapies
and their inhibition, great benefits. So we've had a lot of people with very positive experiences.
All right. I think we'll call it for tonight. We will see everybody back on Monday. I hope you guys
had a great Thanksgiving last week, Monday's, and that you stress free preparation for Christmas.
That's the whole idea, right? Know that I'll be praying for all you guys. I love you all and
done. And I'll see you in about five days. Bye.